well we say that she decided not to but
in reality she is carrying out her
father's will because she knows that
vote on loves is ignorant she has
learned to love zigmund herself through
what she has learned from vote on so she
or she approaches this with a heavy
heart to begin with because she knows
that in reality vote on doesn't really
want to kill ziegland
but coming from this world of you know
these immortal gods
Brunhilde has never seen love she's
never experienced love
she certainly has never seen it between
vote on and freaka that might be an
understatement but um in any event it
touches something in her and it is the
pivotal moment I believe and that's
maybe because I'm a soprano singing
Brunell de but that you know changes the
course of the Ring cycle and so she
decides from observing this relationship
and the fact that he is going to pass up
seeing vote on again he's he's gonna
pass up seeing these other fallen heroes
and the fair maidens that are promised
to him for this woman and even that he
would sacrifice her life before going on
with Brunhilde and that stirs something
in her and she makes the decision to go
against her her father's will and there
are you know horrific circumstances as a
result of this decision but it's also
part of the beginning of what makes her
such a courageous and fantastic
character yeah she has known love
because the love of of her father
towards her vice versa is very important
that's the major theme of the monologue
or the second is not a romantic now but
it's it's it's the the best love
the most lasting but I think in this
case it was it it is a genuine
relationship which is anywhere portrayed
by dogma in a very very honest
relationship in the second act so I
think that of course in the third act
she argues with the father she gives her
arguments he gives his and in fact it's
what what what this P I think but the
whole ring tries to show is that me in
spite of the fact that the gods may
invent series of robots or figures that
they think they can manipulate or
predict the behavior of everything from
beginning to end
you know rolls into one failure rolling
into the other rolling to the other till
the end of the ring nothing that's kind
of the main argument that in a way I
don't think Moulton believes in in the
robot but he is demonstrating in fact
the opposite that he doesn't believe in
the robot that the human beings are
flawed and that you know we will never
achieve perfection because upstairs or
downstairs we are prone to the same
psychological constrictions and and then
paradoxes and contradictions that's what
I personally that's how I have
experienced the ring in as a piece I've
always gone back I've been fascinated
for 40 years by the the myth of the
golem the the which is of course a
medieval Jewish myth from from yeah in a
way that I've also participated in the
making of or not about to goddamn I'm
really very interested in this theme and
I think I've used it in my as an
inspiration also in in in I mean the
golem is precisely that it is a failure
it is about you know the humanity of the
Maharajah the rabbi who creates it
it's about the human flows both of the
creator and created and it's always
helped me very much as a kind of compass
in working on the ring also on pacifier
and laundering which are also about
figure you know artificial figures that
are pseudo human that are playing a role
in the story so I think personally that
the ring is about not not believing in
in the Savior it's it's it's trying to
come to terms with the inevitable
mistakes we we make and we are going to
make the passage that we just saw a herd
decision is the contribution she makes
to the twilight of the Gods that because
she is defying her father and as a
result of that vote on admits at the end
of him the great duet at the end that he
is what does he call himself a nun's a
legion a virgin and unhappy immortal and
that and that now the authority of the
gods has now been usurped and it really
begins with her decision here may be the
best of loves but it is a very unequal
love she is at the beginning of the act
votans will she's identical with him
really this is the scene in which she
begins to emancipate this is not the end
of her her way but this is the moment
when she begins to emancipate herself
from from him this is one thing the
other is what you were talking about
this is the moment when she discovers
that there is something beyond the
Valhalla that there is a certain way of
being in the world that does not that is
not available to the gods and this is a
great discovery which transforms her
from a goddess into a human being and I
think
has to do with limitation and part of
what we were talking about before I
think part of the human experience but
also the experience of love desire first
and love is the experience of limits I
mean it's always it's precisely because
we die that that we are human I can't
conceive of a humanity without the
notion of limit and I can't conceive I
mean I think all of the the history of
poetry the history of the novel and is
about you know is but love and love is
always about the limit it's always
trying to get across the limit it's the
danger of the limit even in twisting and
assault in the in the medieval story
there is always a notion of obstacle and
there's a wonderful book called love in
the web in the Western world by Denis to
who's more where he explains that in
essence really the history of Western
culture is the history of this obstacle
and this this transcendence that is
always a flirtation with death because
this flirtation that this come in close
this obsession with death as a sort of
of ecstasy of blurring the limits of
eliminating the limit we want to
eliminate the limit therefore in this
passionate impulse in this in the behind
the impulse the life impulse that there
is a desire there is there is also
there's a death wish which is both the
it I think them the the going through
the limit the transgression of the limit
is both at the same time I can't
conceive of this I think what you're
saying in terms of her transformation is
also her witnessing this limitation
which perhaps doesn't know before and I
and it's so much part of our experience
here it's part of every it's part of our
experiences in terms of defining who we
are as humans but it's part of even of
our wanted tongue to come out of
ourselves to come out of the limit
ourselves to meet the limit of somebody
else and perhaps in the dream to
transcend this limit we have this idea
of God that the Dove of love water
lapses
that can then be resolved in this in
this sort of fantasy of deathlessness
which in fact can only come to us if we
dissolve completely so there's that the
the end dissolution of court dissolution
is ecstasy but the dissolution only
comes if we go you know beyond the limit
so it always implies a notion of a limit
or in a couple of decades when we have a
pill or an injection you can take that
will reverse aging and let you live
indefinitely at the age that you choose
we will find that almost everyone on
earth prefers to take this pill and to
get old and die not everyone but almost
everyone and we will then find there are
other limits that we're coming up
against so it's not the case we surmount
many limits that squirrels encounter
however we've encountered our own limits
which squirrels cannot imagine and a
superhuman AI may not die an upgrade
Yemen may not die and may be able they
may not have a limit of seven plus or
minus two items in their short-term
memory they may have overcome many many
limits that plague us they may not get
second old they may even be able to fuse
minds with each other into a single
combined mind if they want to rather
than communicating by touch and language
on the other hand that doesn't apply
they will beyond beyond all limits right
I mean that the general process you
described of finding limits and
challenges and then achieving
satisfaction by overcoming these
challenges I mean this isn't what you
described me as essentially inhuman so
it would be another kind of world that
is different difficult to conceive of
just as the dog looking at equations of
the cosmos or inflationary cosmology
can't quite understand it I'm not sure
we're able
you